A lot of
stuff to talk about
with Congress and Ukraine.
I first want to ask you
about what
we're seeing in Monterey
Park, California, in your home state.
Of Texas when a lot of mass shootings.
You've all the Sutherland
Springs, El Paso, Santa Fe, you voted
no on bipartisan gun legislation
last summer.
That got a pretty big bipartisan vote.
It was pretty incremental also.
Would you support any
gun control measures in this Congress?
You know,
I was a counterterrorism prosecutor.
I was chairman of Homeland Security.
You know,
Chicago has probably the
some of the strictest gun
laws in the nation, yet
the highest murder rate.
So, you know,
the way I look at it is
we need the intelligence.
We need information sharing.
We need to connect the dots.
Every one of these cases,
and I guarantee you can see it
in this one as well.
The shooter had warning
signs along the way.
We just didn't respond or pick it up.
So in my judgment,
we can create a system.
I introduced a bill
that we could take
public information on the Internet,
have an algorithm to stop the threat
before it happens.
That is a smart approach
rather than, you know,
violating Second Amendment rights.
And so,
look, I hope we can get that passed.
We're seeing this movie
way too many times.
Yeah, we are.
And it's it's absolutely tragic.
What about a red flag law?
Federal red flag?
Well, in a way,
what I'm talking about are red flags.
And every one of these.
But, you know,
Chicago, Illinois, you know, red flag.
I know what you keep.
You keep bringing up Chicago,
which I understand.
But the guns in Chicago
come in from other places
because there are a patchwork of laws
across the country.
There's no federal law.
Right.
Again,
we stopped
and I saw it when I chaired Homeland.
So many terror attacks
because we
got the threat information in advance
and we stopped it.
We can use that same formula
here, domestic
We although it's a little different,
you know,
the Constitution didn't apply overseas.
But we can do that here
and stop these threats
before they happen.
Let's talk about Russia
and Russia's war on Ukraine.
Ukraine is still asking for more help,
as you well know.
You had pretty strong words about Germany
because Germany
so far is saying no
to transferring its tanks to Ukraine.
You called it a cowardly decision.
What seems like we're at
a pretty key moment in this war.
What do you think
the Biden administration
should do differently with regard
to this particular standoff?
Well, the NATO
secretary general Stoltenberg
called it a pivotal moment.
I think that we cannot slow walk
the weapons in.
And, you know, even The Wall Street
Journal had a great editorial
and they said,
you know,
there's no moral or strategic case
for giving Ukraine
just enough weapons
to to bleed for months,
but not for victory.
I've been a proponent of let's
give them what they need,
because when we do, they win.
The tanks are vitally important.
Why Because we know
with the new General Putin put in place,
they're going to start a major offensive
on the eastern flank in the Donbas.
And we know that's going to happen.
The tanks can help stop that.
Germany will not put one tank in.
Member Germany, Nord Stream two pipeline.
They won't put one take in
until we give them reassurances.
We're going to put our Abrams out.
If we did that publicly,
that would unleash
so many Ledford tanks,
because there are ten other nations
that are looking for Germany.
To sign off on the tanks
that they have given them.
That would be a game changer in addition
to tactical missiles called attack guns.
They can reach Crimea
to take out the Iranian drone.
So, Mr.
Chairman,
are you arguing here for the US sending
Abrams tanks to Ukraine?
100%.
We don't have to send very many.
All we have to do is send enough
to unleash
what Germany has
and what the ten other countries
in Naito have.
Naito has to share the burden.
One good thing that came out of Rammstein
Summit was that NATO
countries are sharing the burden.
It's in their backyard.
It's in their best interest,
and there's no concern
that this could be an escalation
in the eyes of Russia.
You know, they said that with Stingers.
They said that would you have on high?
I mean, what
I think I think Mr.
Putin is a provocative
one here
who's escalated
as he invaded
a sovereign territory
aggressively unprovoked Mr.
Chairman,
a lot of members of your conference,
fellow Republicans,
they want to stop giving money
to Ukraine.
Should Ukraine be worried
that the money
is going to stop coming from the U.S.?
No, no.
I think there's enough support
on both sides of the aisle,
majority in
the Democratic Party,
majority in the Republican.
The national security chairman,
like myself, support this.
We have to educate our members.
I don't think they quite understand
what is at stake
if Ukraine falls
Chairman Xi
and China is going to invade Taiwan.
If Russia, China, Iran is putting drones
in Crimea
and North Korea,
that's putting artillery into Russia.
They have to understand the case
and they talk about the border.
Not mutually exclusive at all.
We can do both. We're a great country.
We can walk and chew gum at the
same time. Let's talk about
some things happening
on the home front,
specifically the revelation
last night that the FBI found six
more classified documents
at President Biden's
private home in Delaware,
and that was after
a 13 hour search,
one that he invited
to get to the bottom of it.
What is your reaction
and do you feel satisfied
now that the FBI has
what it needs and has everything?
I don't know,
because every day it seems like
they're finding more documents.
And so I think
what's significant
is a former federal prosecutor
that no longer
they are relying
on the attorneys to comply,
although it was consensual, the search.
But the fact is,
the FBI conducted
this search, not his attorneys,
that that really ratchets
the investigation up.
But as you said,
they invited the FBI to do so.
They did.
And I think that's true.
I don't know.
The DNI,
director of National Intelligence, won't
I give Congress any information
about the documents
I hear pertains to foreign adversaries?
I don't know.
The Chinese
gave a 30 million contribution
in to University of Pennsylvania.
At the same time,
the Biden Center's being stood up.
And what is their connection
on sending a letter out tomorrow
to the State Department's security?
Blinken
asking for what communications,
what contacts were made?
What were these documents
that were Chinese officials
at the Biden Center
And the fact that they're in the garage
with a Corvette and then a home
where Hunter Biden is recovering
and he took a picture of his laptop
of important documents.
I just think,
Dana, there are a lot of unanswered
questions here. Yeah.
Just just for the record,
University of Pennsylvania said
the Chinese money
did not go to the Biden Center.
And we don't have any
evidence about Hunter Biden
being related to this.
But they have a thousand talents program.
That's the classic way.
I have to ask you,
we're almost out of time.
The debt ceiling,
you have voted in the past
to raise the debt ceiling.
In fact, three times even since 2017
Why not do it now.
Yeah.
And I think
if you don't
you have catastrophic you know
so you go elsewhere.
Well I talked to Kevin McCarthy,
the speaker yesterday.
He made it very clear,
I'm ready to sit down
with President Biden today
to talk about a reasonable debt ceiling,
which would mean more meaningful
spending cuts.
The fact is
we should be having these conversations
right now.
We know that
Secretary Yellen is going to put
she can put this off until June
June's going to be the target month.
But the speaker of the House
is willing to sit down today
with the president,
the United States
and try to work this out.
And I would encourage him to do that.
House Foreign Affairs Chairman
Michael McCaul, thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
And congratulations on your chairmanship.
I haven't seen you since. Thank you.